[Music]
in racist video game news with the
question mark
I love races video games submitted by me
obviously no not me though you know
obviously alright a Chinese American
congresswoman is urging online platforms
to not allow a video game that she deems
is racist and full of stereotypes what
game is that all games there's a Chinese
congresswoman then way to do a story
yeah so this New York City Congress
woman named Grace Ming she posted on
Facebook saying this yep the reader in a
Chinese accent I can't do that you want
to do it no what she's all Asian
American she is a fourth generation
asian-american uh so she said I wish I
could say that I was shocked that there
is a new video game soon to be released
called dirty Chinese restaurant is
[ __ ] up oh [ __ ] that is [ __ ] up
that's too blatant this game uses every
negative and demeaning stereotype that I
have ever come across as a
chinese-american
from the names used for the characters
in the name in the game like oh yeah I
do know it's Wong foo and wing food
where does that set the meeting
uh-huh but let me continue to the types
of food they cook to the distribution
disturbing depiction of their faces this
game epitomizes racism against
asian-americans
I fear that prejudice against and other
of Asian Americans remains a form of
racism to frequently brushed off and
texted Lee accepted racism against
asian-americans is just as harmful and
pernicious as racism against any other
group and we must call it out when we
see it how we portray people matters I
urge Google Apple Android and any other
platform to not carry the game dirty
Chinese restaurant or any other game
that glorifies and hurting any community
so I'm gonna show you guys a clip of the
game the promo game sounds awesome so
far you know it's funny
she's probably helping the game be
promoted even more because I didn't know
anything about this before someone's
gonna like want to download it it is
true so let me know what you guys think
here we go this is who created the game
Big O tree or bigger team as being
politically correct so corn
[Music]
mmm [ __ ] rice heads it's like diner -
good what is the real game some of those
postal more operations market cook Nova
what if this came out straight from
China look for deal oh my god damn you
never gambling den in the back seat
[ __ ] for real
Wow
[Music]
oh my god taxi
No you're taping document at the
cleavers oh my god that's like a game
that YouTube's me I know that game I
mean I don't know where she's from
because I've also seen like like New
York Chinatown I mean like specifically
in New York and I know that Chinese
culture is like really really strong
there where even fourth generation
Chinese there feel really connected to
the roots but I think out here like when
you're an asian-american and because you
see like this fresh batch of fobs all
the time
you feel less and less connected to I
guess to the motherland so when I see
jokes like this for me it's like a fairy
tale it's like that's like some crazy
1970s 1980s jokes and it's so out latch
that it becomes funny
so for me personally I have nothing
against but someone that lives like in
Chinatown like in New York or is around
there where it's actually a booming
being like our Chinatown it's pretty
much like a ghost town understand a
tourist trap but the Chinatown over
there is the actual living breathing
community and if they are fighting these
struggles every single day then I can
see why she is pissed at it but for me
because of where I grew up I to me it's
like it's just so funny that [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] outlandish that I didn't know
anybody would take that [ __ ] seriously I
mean yeah just look at the name of the
company that created the game bago Tree
games it's a for-real game no it's like
there so this is a quote from the from
the company they said it has come to our
attention that our small independent
game dirty Chinese restaurant has upset
our game is mainly satire and comedy
influenced by the classic politically
incorrect shows we grew up watching such
a South part all in the family Sanford
and Son Family Guy Simpsons and
Chappelle show we also listen to jay-z
our game is routed to the Jay Z so makes
it okay
I don't know when JC made it okay to
talk [ __ ] about Chinese people no no our
game is in no way meant to be an
accurate representation of Chinese
culture obviously I don't I don't think
anybody looks at that and says this is
what chai that's like if someone made a
game called dirty redneck a ninja guy
that lives in the trailer park and then
he [ __ ] his sister and he goes around
making moonshine in the backyard and
then he steals [ __ ] and you know like
has one tooth like that probably does
exist it sounds like Oregon Trail yeah
he's just poking fun at extreme
stereotypes I don't know I I like the
first statement in the game about the
whole like PvP practice no boring
everything is so [ __ ] politically
correct nowadays I like games like this
like it follows a congresswoman
I wouldn't ban the game I just want to
see the other games you're gonna create
like I want to see the black game the
Latin game the white game I just want to
see the whole array of games and then if
only the Asian one is like really [ __ ]
up then I'd probably get mad but if all
of them were that outlandish well
worried about them like the people that
are against this game that say like you
know just perpetuates more stereotypes
that are trying to prove the whole
culture away from me because we live in
California and we know that white people
here aren't that [ __ ] stupid to see
that game and actually believe that's
how Chinese people are maybe you know
it's coming from people who live in the
Midwest where there are a lot of
uneducated people who don't understand
like you know they might really believe
that [ __ ] but I don't know anyone that's
that [ __ ] dumb well grace here she's
great from New York you know or like at
least she's a congresswoman in New York
so it offended her it offended a lot of
yeah me I mean it makes sense if like
Bart said like you know New York
Chinatown and their community is they
take that stuff maybe way more seriously
than we do out here I don't know maybe
in her
that's a little bit different just
because she's in politics so she's
probably around and people a lot of
people that aren't so familiar with I
guess Asian culture and then for them
they might just be like where's that
tire not necessarily taking all that
being like oh that's the truth but then
things that they've probably heard
growing up they're probably like okay so
some of these things might be partially
true I think it's an evil that is kind
of necessary though in today's age just
because and I'm only speaking for Asian
American media which is I feel like
Asians or even Asians from you know the
motherland's like I feel like there's a
there's a conscious effort to make Asian
characters Asian storylines be very
stoic and perfect and these you know
perfect heroes and stuff like that and
we never we rarely ever laugh at our
flaws you know I remember Jet Li when he
made fearless he depicted a you know a
really respectable kung-fu master but he
was depicted as a drunk in that film
because you know according to the
filmmakers that's really what happened
to them but then China and the kungfu
community there they got really mad at
Lee and they were trying to ban the film
because they depicted this master for
being you know a drunk yeah like I think
there's a problem there where Asians
don't know how to laugh at ourselves you
know and we did and that kind of holds
ourselves back and in the world of media
and I I agree 100% because I think you
show more strength by being able to like
make that beneath you and laugh at it
yeah it's so outlandish that to take it
seriously makes you seem kind of weak I
feel like the black community went
through it and it was like alright well
we're gonna one-up you guys and show you
like the Mexican or the Latino community
went through it too you know like bet a
bunch of [ __ ] that was considered racist
but then it's like you kind of just put
you know you you work on your craft you
have really good actors and then they
have you know and I mean like they rise
to the top and it's like you expose the
reality of like that's not really what
we I mean I could definitely see some
people being really offended by this
just because if you're like third fourth
or fifth generation like of like
asian-american link you can't really
relate to that
as as much as like those yeah you never
tasted cat before though it's kind of
like we've been here for a while but
then they still look at us as these
strange foreigners that [ __ ] eat cats
all day it's like the Garfield kind of
cat hey guys I hope you enjoyed that
episode of just kidding news and if you
did really enjoy it or if you have
thoughts about what you just watched
leave a comment down below and let us
know and for the next video click right
up here